college basketball's Final Four was
scheduled to be played today instead
because of the coronavirus the NCAA
tournament was cancelled for the first
time in its 81 year history seasons and
dreams ended like those of the Baylor
Bears the team set a school and
conference record this season with a 23
game winning streak one of the reasons
for Baylor success the play of Freddie
Gillespie who as we found out in early
March is a lesson in perseverance and
faith so this is the gym where you lived
Freddie Gillespie had no other choice
arriving at Baylor a perennial NCAA
tournament team and pool for NBA talent
out of little-known Carleton College
have you had a kid like Freddie before
never and I think you just don't have
players today starting out at a Division
three school playing a total of 16
minutes for a whole year and then coming
to the highest level
Scott Drew's in his 17th season as the
Bears head coach when he came here I
joked but he struggled to score by
himself in the gym and what I meant by
that is he was just real raw as a kid in
Minnesota
Gillespie poured his athleticism into
football not basketball his first
organized attempt at hoops didn't come
until the eighth grade I didn't love it
at first
I liked I loved being with my friends
like yeah cuz the teammates and I play
football with almost all of them played
basketball too but the sport itself I
was like all right I mean any time I
touched someone was a foul but after a
year off and a growth spurt which put
him at 64 Gillespie gave basketball
another shot and something changed I was
look more mature a bit more athletic bit
more created by that time so I at that
point said I really kind of fall in love
with it Judy here I decided that I
really kind of wanted to play at the
next level play in college home I didn't
really see division was the opportunity
Division three was and Carlton college
the small liberal arts school close to
Gillespie's Minneapolis area home is
where he landed so I thought that I can
go there still get a nice saw degree
play bass on the side and then kind
my system and then go work my office job
I like that get it get it out of my did
not get it out of your system
I did not know and only good only only
good love the game more and more
Gillespie didn't play his freshman year
but got time in the rotation in his
sophomore season just like in high
school that's when something changed
getting better each game I thought you
know I really feel like there's more to
this in me I really kind of play it in
the next level at a higher level and
then one day I'm just watching a UNC
game but talking about the size and the
length and the athleticism saying you
know one guy's a 72 wingspan I was 76
some of their verticals and I thought I
have all that so what's stopping me and
it's kind of clicked I thought I should
be a division-one Gillespie shared his
dream with his parents just really told
me how I was talking with his love is
because he'd even bat nine she's like
okay for sure this what you want doesn't
you feel well then we'll figure it out
people don't get d3 to d1 does not
happen it doesn't jarred newness an
assistant on the Baylor staff got a tip
about Gillespie from his dad a high
school coach and former college star in
Minnesota who's also a Gillespie family
friend always said you know he just came
to Baylor and had an opportunity to get
have us work with them
[Applause]
most of our walk-ons are about 6 foot 6
foot 2 so you get a 6 9 guy with the 7 6
wingspan that wants to walk on I mean
you are receptive at the same time you
don't necessarily know if they're gonna
flourish and turn out like Freddy
obviously have didn't have a scholarship
for you they made it clear if you're
gonna come here Freddy this is going to
be a walk on it yeah that had to be a
big decision it was I talked to my mom
about it my dad about it and basically
say no it's just how much do you really
you know believe in yourself you know we
believe in you but you're gonna put the
work in
you gotta really take that big step and
walk out on faith that's what I did
which brought gillespie to this gym at
Baylor he sat out that first walk-on
year which might best be described as
his workout year he really benefited
from our strength coach our nutrition
program and all the resources that you
get into power 5 school like Baylor at
the same time all the boring things that
nobody really wants to spend time on he
embraced that working on right left hand
layup reverse right hand reverse left
layup learning your ABCs the very basic
1 2 3 4 you learn a foreign language you
gotta count to 10
yes we're just having just being Ross
the player it was almost unbearable so
how did you bear it I really told myself
it's okay I went in this gym not who
they are
started out where I was at some point
now they may have been seven years old
and they ran at my level I may have been
11 and they got to this point so if they
can do it then I can too and when
Gillespie began doubting himself it was
his mother who reminded him of a quote
from a commercial featuring NBA star
Blake Griffin some of my college coach
told me
not the fall in love with the process of
becoming great when you're tired exhaust
a way you don't wanna go to Prats you
have to enjoy that and find enjoyment in
that or to continue so that's kind of is
what I did I just learn to love you know
the obstacles the bad games the ups and
downs and all of it the result Gillespie
was awarded a scholarship to play at
Baylor starting last season
that was a definite wonder hides in my
life just because you know confirmed all
the hard work and you know confirm that
the people that they believe in me that
they were writing and that I was right
this season as a redshirt senior
Gillespie was named a full-time starter
he was an integral part of a historic
run for the bears and when we visited
Gillespie
Baylor was on track for a number one
seed in the NCAA tournament how much fun
are you having now in a game that you
learned to love in high school I mean
it's even better than I imagined um
every game is amazing and also the guys
that I'm sharing it with too are just
phenomenal I mean having a great season
you know also helps breaking some some
records that was makes a bit more fun
the coronavirus would strike next the
NCAA making it official there will not
be a tournament this season the NCAA
tournament canceled and the Bears run
over but Freddy Gillespie's time in the
game may not be is the NBA a dream of
yours to play in the NBA yeah actually
it is
I mean I love the game and that's the
high I don't wanna play at the highest
level so I was not wanna play gets two
very best the best I said to me yet the
least try I mean at least you know I
mean if you don't try these just you
just told yourself no sense for me so
I'm gonna have to come and tell me no
you weren't good enough anyway that
might not be enough
a couple draft boards right now have
them there's a late second-round pick so
keep watching